foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
how many books we had holy crap
we're live we are live uh
everybody hey
oh oh here we go
welcome to fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I am Mark Bernardin hey oh
uh we were just discussing
um the the this is look at me where am I
I'm in the Game of Thrones room in my
new home
uh this is a room that uh was a bedroom
um when we bought the house but
as I was just talking to Mark about my
something perhaps a lot of people don't
know about my wife
she is a book nut
she is I believe the term is bibliophile
indeed
um but you know of everything we moved
for those that don't follow that closely
the house that I've been living in for
22 years
um we vacated and we're now in this
house in Studio City
where my neighbor the other day I got
hit up
um
Tyler Posey
the the team himself yes
um who was in yoga hosers the ill-fated
yoga hosers
um he hit me up or he's like oh my God
you live on Berry I live on we moved to
Berry Drive in Studio City
and he's like I'm right near you he's
like literally I could go borrow sugar
from right now the king of
only fans
um he's got a huge only only fans page
uh Shatner lives here not here but like
somewhere in the neighborhood as well
so
um in moving what I discovered was
the house we were in over on La Presa
which we'd been in for like two decades
um there were books everywhere but the
house there was so much square footage
that I never really noticed I mean I
knew half the library was books the
other half was where I did fat man
beyond that was my office
but there were bookshelves like
everywhere so most of the move was about
unpacking books and this this
room
books
um this I would say
represents eight percent of the books in
this house
she's she got a serious
collection I.E problem uh but it's never
a problem with his books for having sex
so yeah a lot of books is what I'm
getting at if I was never to sit there
and be like where did all my money go
books the money's in the books it is
yeah literally but although sadly not
within the pages of the hollowed out
books or something but she at one point
she was like I collected like five bins
of books that we could donate I'm like
donate
no like use them to build a new
home or some or sell them on eBay would
donate as my Christian mother used to
say when I was a kid charity begins at
home which never made sense until I was
an adult and I was like Mom Mom's
conflicted
in any event
um yes so we're moved and we're still in
the process of moving and I'm still
figuring out where the I'll
eventually live I have an office
downstairs in the garage which I
absolutely adore but it's still not
completely unpacked and the internet
doesn't reach down there yet
um it's we too weak to do something like
this so I elected to be here for the
time being but downstairs my garage
office looks like Tony Stark's garage
white with high ceilings and you
could literally park a car in there so I
pulled my car something I haven't done
for 20 years never pulled the car into
the garage at the La Presa house here I
pull into my office I get out and my
desk is there it's kind of badass it's
very Batman
that's what it is isn't it I keep
thinking about Tony Stark's garage but
it's literally the cave down
there all you need is a turntable to
just spin your car I wish I have to
back out like a normal schlub
and like that so I ain't got it
that good but yeah it is kind of cool
pulling the car into the garage
and then like there's my desk I hop out
take off my cow
I need some trophies like memorializing
a dead Jason Muse's costume or some such
knocker costume up on the wall
yes
that would really complete the
effect
um but any event all that kids
welcome the fat man beyond and uh
we got so much to talk about including
yesterday was my birthday yes it was
happy birthday thank you so I'm dealing
I'm doing all this as a sadder but wiser
man I'm 53 years old kids
53 years old and at 53 I just
realized that I did not pull the copy
for our ad yes there'll be an ad there
will spoilers
um it's funny my grandfather every every
birthday would always ask me so what do
you know this year that you didn't know
last year and my answer was like nothing
I'm 17 years old I didn't know dick at
17 years old did no dick at 18 years old
but I imagine in that question should I
ask you that what do you know now at 53
that you didn't know at 52
um
could be a a a volume in and of itself
oh my God what a year I've had
um I'm actually in a better place on my
53rd birthday than I was on my 52nd
birthday remembering like
I wasn't a nut house not too
long ago like life life's very fast and
like I remember after I had the heart
attack five years ago one month later it
was like heart attack what heart attack
because I was just right back into it
you get two directions kids either you
stop or you go and sometimes like bad
things happen and you've got to make the
choice to either just give up or
go forward and and so I have been going
forward but in the going forward part of
things
you know every once in a while I'm like
yeah this was a bad year like
it was it was pretty bad but what I
learned what I know now that I didn't
know last year is that I could survive
it that like
I know what's it the source of some of
the
that I've gone through in Life or that
I've continued to go through I know that
I'm insanely codependent I know
that like
I'm a Mr Fix It whoever wants to
repair things for everybody else but
myself
um you know I I this is what I also know
and I was just having this discussion
with my wife which is like I'm sure
everyone's bored as but
like most of our lives together
like I saw this show I forget what we
were watching and somebody talked about
on the show like they were a parent and
they had to give up so much to be a
parent
I never had to do that like I I I've
gotten to live exactly as I wanted to
Live While raising another human being I
never had to stop being
the Eternal teenager I was always kind
of hoping to be that I hoped being in
the entertainment into the field in the
Arts would afford me right like
part of this thing I can't speak for
Mark but I I think I can on some level
nobody goes into the entertainment or
the Arts or writing or any of that
going like I want to grow up no it's
it's about arrested
adolescence childhood to some degree
because when you're a kid that's what
you do you make pretend and you make up
stories and you dream and things like
that and you know when you become an
adult like my old man
you know he didn't go to them to the
postal field because he was like I want
to dream like he took it because it was
a job and it was a job that paid for his
family and most people who go into the
real world and have actual jobs and
don't
spend their time trying chasing youth
which sounds way dirtier than I meant to
but chasing the ideals of Youth the like
the Endless Summer the you know let's
make pretend let's dream for a living
and stuff like that and we breathe
rarefied air and as much as that's
literally how we make our living going
like what would Green Hornet do what
would
Darth Vader do in the case of Mark
having written his comic recently you
know what I wake up every day and I'm
I'm never like oh I've got all this
I have to do I'm like what do I dream
about doing what dream can I put in into
motion now that I could realize later on
and stuff and so because of that
I've lived a very
infantilized you know uh insulated life
where
simple like my bills are paid
by somebody else
um you know Carol who's run my business
since I was a child
um is the person responsible for like
writing checks and making sure the
lights are on I'm I'm responsible for
earning all the money she's responsible
for paying it out in the last few and
and in addition to that like in raising
our kid me and heart and Jen have never
done it alone Jen's parents Byron and
Gail lived with us forever since the kid
was little and stuff so we always had as
much as we were raising a kid we were
still getting raised ourselves I had an
entire second adolescence
because I lived with somebody else's
parents you know the first adolescence I
had living with my own mom and dad and
then like by the time I was you know
hooked up with Jen 28 29
I moved into a house with her parents
when our kid was born so for the last
like 24 years 25 you go even further
back where we were taken care of at one
point Gail was my assistant but she also
like made dinner for us every
night and stuff so
you know I would not say I'm spoiled in
as much as like I paid for all these
things and whatnot and and put in a lot
of hard work to be able to pay for it
but I've always been taken care of
whether or not I've paid for that taken
care of or not
like that was the case now
we're kind of I'm not gonna say we're on
our own because Carol still does
a lot and whatnot but like Byron and
Gail are trying to enjoy what's left of
their lives in their mid 70s so my kid
has her own house and she's often living
and stuff and so oddly enough we are
just now starting to do things
that have been way laid for a quarter of
a century I.E writing checks like in the
last month we've had to go like do we
have a checkbook you know and and
writing handwriting checks so much so
that when you write your own checks like
I remember Chris Rock told me years ago
we were walking on working on Dogma he
was like
don't ever let somebody else pay your
bills he's going because if you pay your
own bills you will turn off a
light in your house
and I just never followed that advice I
never heeded that Sage advice now as I'm
responsible for more for writing checks
than I ever have in the last 20 years
I run around turning lights off
because I'm like that everything costs
money I didn't know this because
somebody else was paying the bills so
oddly enough at age 53 I have grown up
more in the last year than I have grown
up in the previous 24 of them you know
even going as far back as clerks
which were coming up on the 30th
anniversary in January is the 30th
anniversary of its debut
at age 53 I'm finally learning I'm
adulting you know which is I I guess
good
a little bit overrated it really is like
but but this is the time of life
I'm at like you know my her parents
aren't going to be around forever as I
saw from my mom this year with her in
the hospital for 11 weeks and us almost
losing her
all of the trappings of my childhood and
Youth
are going to slowly slip away and for
people who deal in the real world and
they've always understood that
concept I've always had this mindset of
like no man it can be the Endless Summer
but summer will eventually end and that
is something that I've had to face in a
big bad way this year and I'm happy I'm
not regretful I'm not like now I'm
just like you know what
I I I enjoyed the like the freedom of
Youth for a long long time and
now only at age 53 am I like well
perhaps it's time
to embrace being a grown-up
and winter is coming
boy leave it to a writer who
stole from another writer but you're
absolutely right like
it ain't always going to be spring and
summer like at age 53 what do I got
20 25 years if I'm lucky like there is
clearly less life ahead of me than
behind me I'm still living like the
Future's So Bright I Gotta Wear Shades
and that has a lot to do with the job
and making pretend for a living
but you know like we just lost somebody
who perhaps you want to talk about
somebody who kept it young his whole
life we'll get to it by the end of the
show but like we lost the great Paul
Rubens this week and it was a shock to
everyone's system because he kept it
kind of quiet and you're talking about a
guy who kept it really young
professionally
Peewee young for heaven's sakes but
eventually like time runs out for all of
us and perhaps it's best that I embrace
that now
and start understanding and processing
that and living a little bit more maybe
one more foot in the real world than I'm
more accustomed to so no complaints but
at age 53 I'm like oh yeah I guess this
is the year that I've grown up more than
I've ever grown up
historically
um and no complaints like you know how
could I complain I for so long I
didn't have to but now I'm adulting in a
way that I never have before so
that's what I've learned to answer who
is it your father your grandpa my
grandfather and you were broadcasting
live from Winterfell so yes look as you
can see I'm trying to maintain the
iron throne and
life won't have it but the good news is
um you know like Barbie happens
yeah it does which you know reminds you
of like oh yeah life can be
fun and and and you can get surprised by
like there's a movie that I
never imagined I'd be like wow one of
the best movies that's all I saw all
year was a big commercial for a
doll that I never collected
yet wonderful surprises happen all the
time and stuff so yeah it's look above
ground is always the best place to be
and every day above ground particularly
of my age and is a good day so I'm I'm
happy happy I had a happy birthday I
didn't do anything all people like
what'd you do
at one point like I went out to brunch
with the family like three o'clock it
was me and Jen and Byron and Gail and
Harley and Austin and
and then honestly I I slept most of my
53rd birthday I was very tired
I woke up early because the dogs woke me
up and I was writing and and so then
during the day I was like perhaps I
can't and I slept for like five hours of
my birthday but hey okay
listen pop-up needs his afternoons Julie
it doesn't matter that it's like hey
this is your special day I mean look
every as Malcolm pointed out my
friend Malcolm he was just like
for a guy who lives every day
like it's his birthday he's going I feel
like for your birthday you should be
treated like a normal human
being so you he's like I know
everyone else is wishing you happiness
on your special day but you get 364
special days why don't you just
embrace the fact that you're a human
being on your birthday so that's what I
did this year very sweet enough about me
how about you uh I'm I'm doing well man
I'm doing well I uh I've been in a
promotional mode because I got a new
comic book coming out yeah a couple
weeks
I saw this post can you see it oh that's
the Muhammad Ali thing which keeps
melting into fire and it's not supposed
to I'll turn off mine I was like what a
clever cover I know right let me turn
off the virtual background so that you
can see the thing virtual background AI
is part of the problem Mark that's the
problem we're fighting and there you are
embracing it it's your whole background
I know I didn't mean to uh but there it
is the messenger the legend of Muhammad
Ali now is that Illustrated or no it is
it's pretty big who puts this out this
is a first second press
they're good folks it's an imprint of
MacMillan and they just they do graphic
novels mostly for ya audiences but and
this is not not a ya book but it's uh it
talks about some stuff talks about
Muhammad Ali maybe the most famous
person of the 20th century and what is
the um how did that come about did you
pitch it did they pitch you what was the
deal there uh they they actually came to
me I had pitched an editor over there uh
a graphic novel idea that they
ultimately they didn't go for it but the
pitch went very well
and so they called me in
2013 and said hey um we have this this
book we want to do we're we're we're
just looking for the right writer to do
it do you like sports
um we haven't found a lot of comical
people who also like sports do you like
sports I uh I do have a a
occasionally deep interest in sports but
kind of a glancing interest in All Sport
kind of except for like golf
and maybe baseball but like as a kid my
dad my dad is an immigrant
it's from Haiti and so his version of
immersing himself in Americana were
sport
and so he would watch everything he
would watch baseball and football and
hockey and Tennis he would never do golf
because it's golf but everything else he
was just all about and so I would when I
was a kid in the 70s all you could do
was watch whatever was on the television
and so he was a fan I mean these Wide
World of Sports I'm Howard Cosell
Welcome to My World of Sports
um and boxing was another one of those
things like the Olympics was always huge
for him because he got to see his
country's flag which you almost never
get to do if you're an immigrant America
um and so that was just part of my
upbringing was being exposed to and
having like an appreciation for sports
um so she was looking for a sports fan
who also knew how to write Comics
um who also had a bit of the journalist
in them at the time I was still a
working journalist she's like very
research heavy and doesn't hurt if
you're a person of color
like we could have hired anybody to do
it but it wouldn't be a bad idea if
you're going to do a Muhammad Ali book
yeah I was gonna say especially if
you're going to do the Muhammad Ali
story for everyone yeah it's like are
you Muslim no I'm afraid I'm not like I
can't get everything
again a five out of five
um and so it was a long process of like
doing the research and digging into the
story and realizing that maybe a
standard Cradle to grave biography was
not the best path for doing this because
his life is as big as anybody's life was
um someone said we chose 10 moments it
was very much inspired by the the Danny
Boyle Steve Jobs movie where they told
Steve Jobs life through three product
launches and use those moments to be
like oh well here's how he was up
as a dad here I was up as a
colleague here I was brilliant there's
all these things and so we just picked
five moments five rounds of a fight I
mean sorry 10 Rounds 10 moments and try
to to encapsulate a life and then also
being mindful that it's based on a true
story but not a true story hence the
legend of Muhammad Ali some of it I just
made up some of it was like this feels
like it could have happened so maybe it
did
um this I know happened but not at this
time and not in this place let's smoosh
them all together because it's kind of
better that way and then something like
that is there like does the family get a
say or the the thing about Muhammad Ali
being the most famous person in the 20th
century nobody had been written about as
much as Muhammad Ali and pop culture
ending rate
all of it is I'm not going to say public
domain like the inner workers of his
life are still part of the estate but
the things that happened to him the
things that he said in public on the
record are all available so you know the
lawyers were like we actually don't need
the rights you know they had a
conversation I think with the estate
um that I don't think boy any fruit so
that turns out we don't need it
and uh and so yeah so I'm really proud
of it this year for you you don't have
to you're not sitting there strapped
after draft with somebody Redline and
being like hey you can't do this you
can't can't say this can't say that you
never said that that's not the spirit of
the thing that's whatever one of the
most public figures that ever
lived you're right about like the
biggest personality of the 20th century
or the most written about I mean in our
childhood
you could not not hear about Muhammad
Ali I was never a sports kid I knew
about Muhammad Ali my father big boxing
fan so naturally like it was that was
his sport and and so Ali was a big part
of my childhood even though I was not
into
boxing but he was omnipresent he was one
of the first people that knew had a
savvily work with and used the media as
well
you know he was
very much like Stan Lee he was in the
business of selling Muhammad Ali and
could do it better than anybody else
could
um and he fought Superman for Christ's
sake like
that's that's how omnipresent he was he
was a real person in the comic book who
fought Superman to a standstill
when I was working on the Superman
script years ago with John Peters in
John Peter's office
on his wall was the giant he had a mural
of Superman of the cover of Superman
versus Muhammad Ali and I remember at
one point he was he said he was like you
know what the sequel is and he showed me
that cover and I was like really
this is the man responsible for the
giant spider in the third act he had a
vision and that Vision was one day
Superman was gonna fight Muhammad Ali on
screen
in the 90s the late 90s
you know what the kids want
an old box with lights
um so wait so uh who hey it's Banff man
everybody give it up for Batman JC's
here what's up man I'll just throw my
Muhammad Ali the first time I remember
seeing or hearing about Muhammad Ali was
in Coming to America
yeah my first memory of him
I mean I remember him being on The
Muppet Show
I think that was probably the first time
that I that I recognized and outside of
a boxing Wing was like
why is he almost gonna punch Kermit in
the face
he fought Superman why wouldn't he fight
Kermit I mean checks out
um if anyone though you fight Miss Piggy
because she was always like yeah he's a
Bruiser she's a Bruiser that one you
ready for it ready for fighting yeah so
it's been a you know setting up like
podcast interviews and doing some press
and you know starting to talk about you
know events potentially I've been
talking to one Mike zepzik about a thing
when you come out in August indeed much
like we did last time last time we had
an Adora signing when we did The Ides of
Mark and now that we're now that we're
gonna do the keep calm and Curry on and
a fat man I think on that Saturday we'll
do another signing at the stash 8 25
August 25th is the fat man beyond
that uh smartcastle sold out kids
8 26 on the Saturday is when we're doing
keep calm and Curry on that's a double
feature the Tim Curry double feature of
clue followed by Legend and that's at
night so you're saying during the day at
the secret stash Jay and saw the Bob's
secret stash in Red Bank New Jersey
indeed doing a messenger signing as well
as signing whatever else Donnie
whatever the else at noon I believe
is the time we uh the time kids we're
three weeks away from that make your
plans accordingly man if you're anywhere
on the East Coast or near the East Coast
sounds like there's a signing in your
future come on out and see Mr Mark
Bernardin signing hold it up again
but in front of you
there you go the messenger Who's the
artist
uh fellow named Ron Salas
um who uh he is I think he lives in
Atlanta I want to say okay
um but wonderful Dude immensely talented
um born in the Philippines came to the
states and decided he wanted to
make comic books and God bless him for
doing so because he's amazing how can I
yeah man
um and how nice to be able to talk about
writing
because for the last 80 plus days the
only talk about writing you've been
doing is holding a sign I know today's
94 I believe is it really Day 94. Day 94
next next Wednesday is the 100 day Mark
of the
2023 writer strike is that the longest
it's ever gone or is the last Rider's
Guild strike equally as long the last
writers Gold Strike was 100 days I think
the longest it had ever gone I want to
say was like 130 some odd days
um now we were talking right before we
got uh online that uh news broke
yesterday or the day before I think
that uh the amptp
uh negotiators reached out
to the wga about coming back to the
table and talking I think on Friday or
something like that yeah the um the
alliance of Motion Picture television
producers
um
they they reached out to set a meeting
to have a discussion about opening
discussions again it's one of those it's
like when you see a trailer and there's
actually a trailer right in front of it
that says this is the trailer for X all
right now watch the trailer for X it's
all in the same two minutes it's like I
don't need a trailer for a trailer guys
show me the trailer it's all advertising
this is we're setting a meeting to set a
meeting
so parse that out that's nothing but
positive right
um you know it's it's a good sign given
that for 94 days there's been no
conversations at all nothing they
haven't reached out in fact we've seen
some of the press coverage has been
downright horrible like the you
know as we all know Ron Perlman was like
we know where you live and
yeah article houses lose their
Apartments like you know is your
apartment it's not that hard oh
Hellboy it's coming for you right before
the SAG strike broke and a lot of people
feel like that's what pushed it over the
edge
peace I guess it was in deadline where
you know they quoted some
amptp member who was like look the plan
is to starve them out like you
know when it gets close to Christmas and
they got mortgages to pay we'll wait it
out until then and should until they're
about to lose their houses like you know
and I'm paraphrasing but like it wasn't
that far from what it was like their
Apartments lose their houses we know
it's going to happen then they'll be
desperate and then they'll make the kind
of deal we want them to make kind of
like the last thing in the world you'd
imagine like read the room like that
anyone would want out there in the world
but the the online the people who are
kind of pulling it apart and whatnot or
theorizing that the reason that somebody
like that wasn't like overheard through
a glass against a wall somebody put that
information out there hoping to scare
sag into not striking right and it said
it had the absolute reverse effect where
sag was like oh you comic book
villains and decided to strike and and
joined you know the wga in the strike
line as well and then the day after that
a bunch of people were walking back
those comments going like what I
gotta don't speak for us what the
um we never knew who that guy was but
Ron Perlman seemed to indicate that he
knew who it was he did he I mean and
maybe he does maybe there's some kind of
Hell communication that he's still got
wind of
um even though he's not in the Hellboy
costume anymore the Demonic uh the demon
Webb he still has access to but you know
and and various people in various Duty
heads have said you know not entirely
wonderful things not entirely well
reasoned things you know I mean you know
David zoslov just recently was like ah
this strike saved me a hundred million
dollars and it's like
who's who are you Mr Burns like
again read the room man like nobody
nobody out there is rooting for the
Studio I mean that's not true
definitely online there have been some
people who are like Hollywood needs to
do better anyway them all but most
people of course are on the side of the
working person and in the beginning
there were some people who are like well
these millionaires just want more money
and now the truth is out at across many
fronts but writer's Guild then sag that
like the idea of a working writer or a
working actor isn't somebody who's
making
a million dollars not even
a hundred thousand dollars a year you
know in the SAG way you're talking about
some cats who can't even reach the 26
000 a year that lets their insurance
kick in so it's not a series of rich
people trying to get richer it's a bunch
of people who are just trying to get
paid what they're do in an
ever-changing land business
landscape where
more of the pie seems to be going to
upper management than the people
that actually do the work
so
them reaching out
is not like you know Ding Dong The Witch
Is Dead we won but it is a positive step
it's a positive step specifically
especially because there had been no
such step you know and especially it is
hard to explain to to people not in the
business that the writers and the actors
are striking but we're not striking
because we want to we are not the ones
who walked away
um we are not the ones who who are not
willing to negotiate
it's the producers in the studios who
are the ones who are forcing us to
strike and so the fact that they are now
you know for whatever reason decided hey
maybe now it's time to end this thing
maybe we found a way internally to make
all of our members happy because there's
there's two giant land masses within the
amptp there's your legacy Studios your
Sony your Paramount your Universal your
Warner Brothers you know your Disney
um and then there's Amazon Netflix and
apple right tech companies that moved
into into the business and like Sony
just wants to make TV shows you know
Paramount just wants to put stuff on on
CBS you know Universal what's up on NBC
you know Disney despite the fact that
they also were in parks and and and
streaming and whatever it's like Abbott
Elementary's not on the air right now
and that's the show that we want to have
like csis now in the year NCIS is not in
the year anything set in Chicago is not
on the air and that's the way to these
companies all of NBC slate right there
pretty much all all of Chicago and then
the Night Court are not on the air right
now right and so you know they are not
as overwhelmingly invested in streaming
the way that that apple and and flex and
Amazon are they got to get stuff on the
air to sell ads they got to get stuff on
the air to to make good to their
advertisers and to their buyers like
there there's two very different blocks
that want very different things and I
feel like the Legacy block is like no we
have to be done with this
like they're right it's not going to
cost that much money
we'll make a really good deal we'll be
able to save face because again this is
ridiculous that it's gone 100 days but
whatever let's go back to work quickly
to make our money
um and so hopefully that's the sentiment
that's that's sort of rule in the day
and that's where we're going to come
into these conversations with that will
lead to real negotiations that can lead
to an end of the deal and into the
strike and we can all get back to work
because that's all anybody wants to do
why now all of a sudden are they like uh
let's go back to the table does it have
anything to do with barberheimer there's
you know Barbie and Oppenheimer have
been
undeniable Boons for the box office and
I don't just say that as a guy who reads
the news I'm a film exhibitor you know I
own a movie theater I don't know if
anybody knows this but I own a movie
theater called Spa Castle Cinemas and
Atlantic Highlands New Jersey so now I
see things from also another Vantage
Point as a member of NATO the National
Association of theater owners
um it's been a tough summer man
and like we live and die by how much
popcorn we can sell not by how many you
know tickets movie tickets we sell
because a large portion of that goes
back to the studio so for us we're in
the concessions business and business
has been bad because the movies have not
been connecting you know Flash
flushed
um even uh well Shazam shazin
prior to that and Indiana Jones you know
was not
the Savior that we were hoping and
Mission Impossible has been
soft compared to like say Top Gun 2 last
year right oh I remember like most of
the summer people were writing articles
about the only hope is barberheimer and
I remember being like well then we're
because of these movies tried and true
franchises and intellectual property
can't save the day how the is a
movie about a doll the two-hour
commercial about dolls and a
movie about the guy who created the
nuclear bomb that's three hours long how
are they the best hope for the box
office and proving that I don't know
that's exactly what they were Ernie
smart Castle keeper Ernie O'Donnell was
was texting me photos of a line down the
block something that we only see at
smodcast Castle when we're doing fat man
beyond or showing Mall Rats or
Chasing Amy or something like that which
chasing Amy's coming back to Smart
Castle September 23rd with Joey Lauren
Adams tickets it's mycastle cinema.com
so if it's been a healthy period at the
box office at least at my box office and
definitely the worldwide box office
thanks to both to the double phenomenon
of Barbie and Oppenheimer truly the
saviors of Summer
2023. does that have anything to do with
why the amptp is like hey we should get
back to work because
apparently people want to go to the
movies I mean I think it definitely
doesn't hurt you know I think it
definitely doesn't hurt in that this and
Mission Impossible these two movies in
Mission possible were the last movies
where Stars could promote and they did a
lot of that promotion in advance because
they knew like hey things are beginning
to like we see the tea leaves starting
to coalesce we see the tarot cards begin
to flip let's start backing that we
can begin to spool out over the course
um of of July and and and early August
but they're also looking at award season
they're looking at the Venice Film
Festival Toronto Film Festival they're
looking at fear consideration events
they're looking at the Emmys they're
looking at
television most especially like if they
want to rescue the first quarter of 2024
if they want to have new TV on in
January February writers need to get to
work in like September in order to shoot
in December and have anything ready to
go by January you know if you want to be
like making the movies for next
Christmas if you want Doom to come out
and do what it's supposed to do if you
want to Aquaman too to come out and do
what it's supposed to do then you need
to have your stars out to promote you
need to be able to hit the ground with a
full chord press and do that and right
now none of that can happen and so I
think that Barbie might have been the
smack in the ass to get the baby to cry
and be like oh you guys what are we
doing here we'd like to have another
billion dollar week please
um let's let's find a way let's find a
way to make a way to uh to to get
everybody back to work and the Studios
have started moving 2023 movies into
2024.
um a bunch of movies that were scheduled
for the end of this year have now been
pushed into next year because they're
like I guess somebody somewhere was
quoted like no movie star no movie in
terms of promotion you know Disney
uh the strike happened right before the
Haunted Mansion Premiere and so the
haunted print Mansion Premiere was not
Rosario Dawson and and and uh
Keith Stanfield it was Cruella Deville
is walking the carpet ladies and
gentlemen hey Goofy's here like yeah he
literally resorted to people in costumes
to have any sort of semblance of a
Premiere which caught any attention and
as we saw by the box office numbers of
haunted mansion that certainly didn't
help on iota
so maybe it's just maybe they are having
a maybe they've had their wake-up call
maybe it's like look
can't afford this anymore yeah fingers
crossed that that discussion
moves the plot forward in a way where
you're right it's like if they want
anything by January they got to be
starting now
yeah like there's because even even if
you said tomorrow guys strikes over
let's get back to work you've got to
like
notify everybody you've got a like
office space and just time and sets and
locations and all of the the engineering
of making content needs time to get up
to speed and not the least of which is
people have to write this stuff people
got to write these scripts you know show
you know you and I were in conversations
about you know maybe doing a show that
maybe might be on the air at some point
we're starting at Ground Zero on that
thing I mean we don't have any scripts
because we were not allowed to write
these because we didn't sell the show
yet but if somebody bought the show
tomorrow it's conservatively speaking
two and a half months before we have a
thing that you could shoot
and that needs the the sooner you want
stuff the sooner you got to come to the
table and make a deal that uh that makes
everybody happy and let me tell you
something kids this show that Mark is
talking about uh referring to which we
can't talk about obviously
is in not just in the Wheelhouse of this
audience but like in the heart soul and
crotch of this particular audience the
fat man beyond uh audience and who we
wound up in business with because like
Mark said we haven't sold it yet but we
did partner up with with uh a production
company that
you we couldn't ask for better
placement like if we had gone out into
the marketplace if there'd been no
writer's Guild strike chances are we
would have sold this thing like that now
good news is with everyone having been
hungry for the last nearly 100
days if the writer's Guild strike gets
solved and we're allowed to go out and
pitch this thing
I have I I feel like it's gonna sell
fast not just because it's a
great concept something that like if you
watch this show it was last year not the
most recent San Diego Comic-Con but last
San Diego Comic-Con Mark was like I got
an idea I want to talk to you about and
he was like we didn't talk about on the
air but backstage right after that show
ended so we're coming up on the one year
anniversary I know very good idea
like I was like oh my God yes yes yes
um
never mind the fact that it's just a
good idea they're gonna be so hungry for
content
that I think it puts us in Play Rather
fast man and if this thing does
what it should and could do and goes
where it should and could
we're gonna make a lot of people
happy man it's particularly in this
audience it's like
it's a very very cool project so yeah we
we can't move forward on that until the
writer's Guild strike is solved
so far that it gets solved
I forgot about that like nearly 100 days
where it's like we're sitting in a
really great position and then
all of a sudden it's like we can't do
anything all right and this is just one
of a thousand stories of writers who are
out there just waiting to go on stuff
who are waiting like I had the thing the
contracts were in hand we had to stop
negotiating we had to we had to we had
to and then when it's over like it's
gonna be the running of the
bulls of people with ideas racing out
there and hopefully a hungry uh a hungry
series of buyers we're like yes the
pipeline is dry fill the pipeline that's
good let's go make a show a world of yes
that's what we're hoping for at this
point indeed yes please
um it is uh you know um this show kids
which uh whether you like it or not
um is uh brought to you by a sponsor and
we gotta bring those bonds down because
we've been talking for a minute without
even hitting up our sponsor uh this
week's episode of uh fat man beyond uh
is brought to you by the kind folks the
good people
the non-objectionable yes the the
uh folks we've had let's see without
going deep into it we've had many
sponsors on this show
all wonderful one of them turned out to
be pretty problematic across the boards
tonight's sponsor not problematic at all
man in fact helpful particularly if
you've got a lot of bush
that's right we're talking about the
good Folks at manscaped kids manscaped
is helping us uh get to you today man uh
and just to start with a call of action
before we dive deep you're going to get
20 off in free shipping with the code
Fatman 20 at manscapes.com go there
right now while we're talking
and surf around and stuff because that's
20 off with free shipping at
manscapes.com use the code fatman20
manscape beard hedger one stroke one
guard 20 lengths man ladies and
gentlemen it's time to unleash the beach
Beast Within you this summer manscaped
is here to help you level up your beach
game with their new beard hedger Pro kit
that's going past Waist Deep In The
Grooming game and diving in head first
to your facial hair fantasies that's
right these cats are so big they've
moved above the dick
manscaped is now conquering your
face
they conquered your nuts now they're
like let's take the rest of the body
let's take the face man
not the face some people say manscape
says nothing but the face the beard
hedger is a game changer allowing you to
shape your beard Like A true beach babe
so this summer let the beach balls
bounce
they always got that clever copy turn
heads all over the place visit
manscape.com and use the code Fatman 20
for 20 off
and free shipping go ahead Mark it's
time to paint your Maine so take a
bottle you're still in trouble with
manscapes beard heads or Pro kit it all
starts with a beard hedger first off
this cordless trimmer has a rotary wheel
that gives you 20 hair cutting lights
all in one guard so no more messy
drawers full of extra add-ons plus it's
waterproof so you can shave in the
shower to avoid all that hair in the
sink the titanium coated tea blade is
tough on hair but smooth on your face
leading to single stroke efficiency and
brings satisfaction one stroke at a time
little kid doesn't end there though they
have created four dermatologist tested
formulations for your post trim care
first there's the beard shampoo and
conditioner you need to remember your
hair all your hair is different the
beard hair is more coarse and easier to
damage than the hair on your head that's
why the kid has made shampoo and
conditioner specially designed to
moisturize reduce ingrown hairs replace
natural oils and promote beard health
next the kid has manscapes beard oil
this helps relieve dryness both on the
beard and the skin beneath while adding
a little Shimmer and shine
cap off the kit with a beard balm a
Pomade that shapes Styles moisturizes
and tames for a sculpted look to attract
any followers fellows or Dans
the pro beard kit also comes with three
free gifts a beard brush comb and
scissors to ensure your beard is ready
to impress
what are you waiting for
what are you waiting for kids
um you're gonna get 20 off and free
shipping with the code fatman20 at
manscape.com that's 20 off with free
shipping at manscaped
m-a-n-s-c-a-p-ed.com and use the code
Fatman 20. manscaped beard hedger one
stroke one guard 20 lengths we thank the
good Folks at manscaped for a sponsor in
our show and B being the least
problematic sponsor out there just
just good folks that we don't get a
thousand tweets from people going did
you see this
we did we did
guess what we had a reaction kind of
just like yours
um so thank you to the good Folks at
manscape uh for sponsoring fat man
beyond okay I'm not entirely sure why uh
authentic Frontier gibberish was the
voice that I've decided to go one
manscape that but it felt right I buy it
well good news is you're not a sag
member so you can do whatever you want
performance wise funny voices are my
forte for free where shall we uh begin
uh well we can we can start with with
the the the two-headed Colossus that is
Barbie and Oppenheimer now have you seen
Oppenheimer I have seen Oppenheimer all
right so you're one better than me
Barbie
excellent I went back I was back East
last week we did a live script reading
of Superman lives for my birthday packed
out so it was wonderful but that was
Saturday night so on Friday night I did
a watch with Kev Barbie
and uh man like we had a good crowd
um you could pay an extra five bucks to
watch it with me and I intro and then do
the long ass q a afterwards for a movie
I had nothing to do with or you could
pay like the 10 bucks that's our
standard ticket price at spy
Castle Cinemas and watch it without me
and so the night we did watch with Kev
Barbie we had a like 140 people for
watch with Kev
about 40 people who were like nah I
don't need to watch it with him I'm good
I just want to watch a movie Get the
out and I don't give a what
silent bills it always blows my mind
always crazy insulting to me where I'm
like for five bucks less you would watch
it without me and 40 people were like
yes
so important life lesson kids not
everyone's gonna like it um you're gonna
be somebody from raisin but it was
um
I look I I I I really loved Lady Bird so
I know Greta Gerwig is talented the
moment I started seeing those trailers I
was like oh this looks like it's
gonna be fun when they first announced a
Barbie movie I was like I wasn't as
uh incredulous as I was when they
announced a Lego movie when they
announced The Lego Movie I think on
Hollywood Babylon I was like this is
dumb and then The Lego Movie
turned out to be like one of the
greatest movie going experiences of my
young life or old life it was a
wonderful flick that stands as test of
time magical
Lord and Miller magical
um so when they announced Barbie you
know Having learned from the Lego I
wasn't like on it going like
this is gonna suck or anything like that
but I didn't honestly think this movie
was necessarily going to be for me when
I saw their first trailer which like had
the you know hats off yes to the
filmmakers uh or the filmmaker in this
instance but definitely hats off to to
the marketing behind Barbie because
saying
um if you love Barbie you'll love this
movie and if you hate Barbie you'll love
this movie really had me intrigued where
I was like
that's absolute confidence
um so I stepped into Barbie I watched it
with my kid and her boyfriend because
they came back East for the script
reading as well
to say that I was like profoundly
shocked at how wonderful the movie is
like this movie is so much better than
it has any right to be
taking nothing away from the filmmakers
this is a two-hour commercial for a doll
like no two ways about it Barbie is a
product
but if Barbie was a plastic doll
for 50 plus years uh Greta
gerwick gave it a soul like quite like
the Blue Fairy she came in and and
turned it into a real live girl
this Barbie flick is wonderful
um insanely well made I went in for the
Ryan Gosling of it all because I think
he's hysterical when he does
comedy and believe me he
delivered and he was the MVP of the
movie as far as I'm concerned
but man oh man did they tell a beautiful
story and Margot Robbie deserves
all sorts of plaudits for carrying this
movie on her shoulders
um you know we knew she could be funny
with Harley Quinn she's done that but
this was a tall order man and the
pairing the Dream Team pairing of Greta
Gerwig and and Noah bombach are
boyfriend or I think they're dating
right they're not married yeah and they
are together in whatever you would call
adult people who are together yeah
um and he's a filmmaker in his own right
and has been for years and years Kicking
and Screaming amongst other things he's
done
Mr jealousy if I remember correctly wait
in the whale I think is his yeah squid
in the well which is wonderful flick but
these two kids got together and wrote a
picture
for the ages you know it's a phenomenon
right now in this moment that saving the
box office no doubt about it but this
movie will stand the test of
time man
um it it is it's better than any movie
about a doll has any right to be
and just proves that in the hands of
great storytellers you can tell a great
story doesn't matter what the
material is man there's a line in this
movie
that when it happened and it happened in
the third Act
and JC perhaps we should throw up that
spoilers thing
just in case folks are like hey man
don't spoil Barbie but who the
hasn't seen this movie yet at this point
it's made of 800 million dollars
worldwide it's it's a hair away from
hitting a billion dollars and it's only
been out for two weeks at this
point
but at one point uh the creator of
Barbie as played by Rhea Perlman
um
says something that I was like I'll
write my entire life and never write
something so beautiful
when she says like I enjoy the movie a
lot and I was like man this is great
this is clever as good on these
kids they deserve all the success and
this line transcended it
for me to Classic territory when uh Raya
Perlman as the Korea as Ruth what was
her name uh Handler I don't know Ruth
Handler I think the creator of Barbie
and they even got in shots there you
know and as much as like tax evasion and
which if you know the if you ever
watch the toys that made us and watched
the Barbie episode or ever watched a
Barbie documentary
you know it's it's
the lady that created Barbie who created
it for her kid and named it for her
daughter Barbara
had some tax issues
they pulled no punches Mattel lets
itself get made fun of
um everybody takes a shot in this movie
but they have the Ruth character say
this one line which I was like Jesus
Christ I had to write it down right away
because I didn't want to forget it and
the lime was uh she was talking about
being the mom of her daughter Barb
Barbara who she named Barbie for and she
said I'm gonna try to get through
without getting choked up but she said
we mothers
stand in place so that our daughters can
one day see how far they've come
like yes of course it works for
daughters that works for any child of a
mother
um I am I'm the son of a mother and even
though I'm not the daughter of her
mother and yes I'm sure that line has
even more impact
for the daughter of a mother but for the
if that made me call my mother that lime
was so beautiful I was like Mom
Barbie made me call you and she's like
oh tiger if you're if dolls are talking
to you perhaps you should go back to
that mental hospital but
that's that that line a line that
good
has no right to be in a movie about a
doll and yet here we are man
it's like that's
it was some wonderful wonderful
funny as
tells the story of you know Barbie
going through an existential
crisis and then leaving Barbie land
which is hysterical and coming to the
real world and whatnot
you know I understand there are some
folks of course who are like I got
issues with this movie because
they go at you know men hard I I felt
they wanted everyone hard you know I I
felt like no one was left unscathed it's
a satire to say the least right would
you classify and qualify this movie as a
satire I think I think I think it
totally qualifies as that I mean it is a
lot of things all at the same time right
like it's
100 satire it's also like a sort of deep
commentary on like the commodification
of feminism you know and like
the a scathing kind of look at the
shallow Simplicity of the patriarchy
right horses my Mojo Dojo Casa house
like I just gotta have this for I
thought it was hysterical how
into horses
and at one point Ryan gossa Ken who is
an
essential part of this movie
um because historically he's always been
and Ken
um but when he was just like I lost
interest in the patriarchy when I found
out it wasn't about horses
such a fantastic line it was such a
funny movie and adorable
um but real and real smart
uh clever within an inch of its
life firing on all cylinders
like as a writer I was like
gotta step up my game man
because if you can do this with a studio
movie there's a big ass Warner Brothers
movie that was you know
engineered to make a lot of money budget
of this movie is is a hundred million
and change
they used up all the pink paint in the
world apparently God and they're clearly
it's meant for Mass consumption
and anything meant for Mass consumption
is usually spoon fed to the audience and
kind of
non-offensive across the board so that
everybody can enjoy it and yet what
makes this movie so powerful
is that it pulls no punches and does
take risks which
for a movie of this size and a studio
movie is it's not normal
like risks are not take the only risk
that a studio is used to making is the
financial calculated Financial Risk of
how much it costs versus how much it
could make
but to let her get away with what she
got away with in the storytelling of
this movie
it it really just shows that like let
more artists take chances even
with gigantic movies that are meant to
please across the boards
this is what they call a four quadrant
movie or at least what they were aiming
for and yet on paper
it would seem that perhaps it wasn't
designed to be a four quadrant movie and
yet somehow works as one am I crazy I
mean I think that that the the dirty
secret of the four quadrant movie was
always the important quadrant was men
between 18 and 34. and if we got any
other quadrant we'd be happy about it
you know but like we're gonna make this
pirate movie who are pirate movies for
for dudes kind of always have
been all right but we're gonna put you
know Keira Knightley in here and we'd
have Johnny Depp and he's gonna be fun
so old people will like it there and
Keira Knightley will you know ladies
will like it because Caroline is there
and it'll grow past that but we know we
just got to get the boys this is a movie
that's like it's a four quadrant movie
but the first pillar of those four
quadrants are women
you know they're and it's the the meme
that's been going around which is kind
of Apt is that Barbie is Black Panther
for white women
which I'm like yeah is that what people
are saying yeah and it's like you're
kinda right in that like if you were if
you were a black person you were going
to see black panther because they had
never made a movie like that before that
was very specifically about you and
culture and and and that part of the
world and all that they had never made a
movie of this scale for women you know
and that has production Design Within an
inch of its life you know had great new
music you know had you know movie stars
that you could relate to about leaving
one world and going into another world
about how those worlds are changed
because of that that that transaction
about how your villain thinks that maybe
the way this world has been operating
this whole time is wrong because I've
learned some stuff about the modern
world and I've got to bring it back to
this other world like Ken is killmonger
in that movie
with a vision for how the world should
work how we should change it we we need
more horses and jackets guys everybody
gets to have a Mojo Dojo Casa house but
I don't know what you're going to do old
person who used to be the ruler of this
place you got to find a place or not or
we gotta have a showdown
and it's kind of not it's not the same
movie but it does a lot of the same
things and
and so this was a movie but hey you know
it's 52 of the population is women what
if we just gave them a movie and would
be happy if guys came along
and I think that's kind of what happened
is like every woman felt the need to go
see this movie because if you love
Barbie You're Gonna Go you hated Barbie
you're gonna go and nobody has a
complicated feeling about Barbie like
women have complicated feelings about
Barbie and they like
like they pull no punches like
it is not presented as like you know hey
man everyone loves Barbie it's presented
in the movie proper like some people are
like I hate there are characters
that are like I hate Barbie yeah
it's it's mind-bending
how much
how how
it would be like making an Indiana Jones
movie and being like
you know half the time you're like well
he's a grave robber isn't he that's bad
like it's just there's there shouldn't
you leave this where it is Indy Museum
no it belongs to the people you've
stolen from put it back they I cannot
think of like a recent movie where the
main character
isn't like lionized particularly when
the main character is a product
that they want to sell and continue to
sell and has historically sold
like
they you get to see the strings in this
movie the fact that Mattel
let them go as hard as they go at Mattel
and you know it's it I it's it's still I
reel from like I can't believe they got
away with this this ain't we're not even
talking a Mad Magazine level of ribbing
this is like a National Lampoon level of
ribbing in terms of like what they did
with their subject matter which
their subject matter has been a sacred
cow for 50 years man that Mattel
was like go ahead
like take the gloves off make fun of
Barbie make fun of Barbie's audience
make fun of us just makes it that much
more wonderful because you don't feel
sold to like when I did the Q a after
the movie I was like
I mean we literally just let's make no
bones about it we just watched a
two-hour commercial
that being said did you feel sold to not
at all it was
it was a miracle it's no wonder why the
movie is doing the business it's doing
and why it's exciting people and
bringing people back
to the theaters man like you're do you
want to talk about making something for
an underserved audience Heavens yeah the
thing that I that I was astonished by
was that I'm not sure you could have
made a movie that says all the things
about feminism and patriarchy and and
and and corporate greed and all that
stuff without it being a Barbie movie I
think Barbie is the vehicle that lets
you tell that story and so like let's
say that that gretiger was like I ought
to do like little bird I want to do a
thing about the patriarchy and feminism
and what that all of that means give me
12 million dollars that I'm gonna make
an indie about it I don't know if that
works as well as it does with a Barbie
in it because Barbie is that totem it is
that fertility God that lets you
tell all of those stories and lets you
have them mean something because it
becomes rooted in our own Collective
kind of Pop memory we'll know what it is
we all think we know what it means but
what does it mean even to its intended
audience who is Barbie you know and to
have a movie that just interrogates that
like what does it mean to be this
doll what does it mean to live
in this prefab Paradise what does it
mean to be a girl who played with
Barbies and what does it mean to realize
that you are never going to be able to
attain the lofty goals that Barbie set
for you what if it what does it mean to
just be like kind of okay Barbie
is that a thing you can be happy being
just regular non-problematic Barbie or
I'm up Barbie I'm weird Barbie
there's a really beautiful part in the
movie I was talking to um
my friend Kim about it she was talking
about the the moment in the in the flick
which I remember when it happened I was
like oh maybe this will pay off later on
but it didn't but it didn't need to pay
off later on when Barbie's in the real
world and she's sitting on a bench next
to an old lady that moment broke my
heart like it's so beautiful where she
just looks at her and she's like you're
you're really beautiful and you know I
was like all right what's the payoff and
that was the payoff that somebody's so
fake and plastic
somebody who will be eternally young
eternally beautiful
looked at someone real
and saw something missing in herself
that's what I kind of missed in that
moment and didn't understand until it
was explained to me later on but the
notion of like
the reason why she was like you're
really beautiful is because she has
never been that and would never be that
on the path
that she was and there is something
really beautiful about being human about
aging about not looking perfect
and
it it that like and that moment happens
not in like the third act yeah but like
in the first few moments of when she
gets to the real world which happens
pretty early in the flick yeah like the
bridge between act one and act two it
you know this movie is special
man and like
you could work your whole life
trying to make a movie like this trying
to make something that connects like
this trying to do something
within the system this ain't an
independent flick where it's
just like hey man I get to do whatever I
want because like it's a no budget movie
this
was made within the system like
I'm I'm really happy for her man like
that's
she's only what three movies in on her
career technically like a little woman
like a ladybird Little Women did I feel
like there's something else in there
about it we'd have to do a quick IMDb
check
but in terms of like movies with budgets
and like that
this is a glow up if this reminds me of
like Spike Lee hitting do the
right thing third time out
Jesus Christ like I don't envy you
you're gonna have to learn to
surpass this or try for the rest of your
career and most of us would be happy to
have one of these and stuff
but man oh man
phenomenal like
warm wonderful funny biting
just good and anybody out there that
hasn't like given a shot yet like on oh
I think I know what this movie is you
don't you don't you really don't like
you know and I know we're a
couple of softies and and we're not
exactly like Mount Rushmore for the
patriarchy me and Mark and and
but
even I who about as liberal as it gets
and I would say Mark probably the same
way
was
flabbergasted
at what this movie
was versus what I thought it might be
um because I remember Mark hit me before
he saw it before I did he was like have
you seen Barbie and said not yet I'm
going to see it this weekend and I
believe you just wrote wonderful or this
movie's great like legit great
you know and also the idea that
as shallows as Barbie as shallows
Barbies can be as the movie presents it
everybody can be a Barbie
you know like there's black Barbie
there's white Barber there's Asian
Barbie there's fat Barbie there's
differently able Barbie there's trans
Barbie like it's just Barbies all the
way down and like that level of of both
awareness of the audience what the
audience is looking for and the subtle
Jabs at who gets to call
themselves a woman who gets to call
themselves beautiful who gets to be in
the spotlight and like everybody does
you know and it's it is not at all the
message of the movie but it's all there
it's all text and if you're reading the
text then you get it if you don't I mean
you're going to be the dude who's just
pissed off because it's anti-mail it's
like it kind of is and that's also kind
of fine like does it hurt that bad to
not have one movie that caters to you
that's why it's you know black panther
for white ladies because it honestly
never felt like oh my God I'm being
talked down to like
watching that movie I was never like I'm
being alienated and like it I I felt
like
I don't know I just felt like I got
ribbed like everybody else got
ribbed I felt like I took it no harder
as a man than Mattel did as a
corporation
like if you're not if you can't
laugh at yourself or at the reality of
what the world truly is like outside of
Barbie land
you know I
I feel bad for you like everyone has to
be able to have a sense of humor about
themselves and about the world we live
and how else do you get through
yeah we live in
um hats off to uh America is America
Ferrara yeah
yeah you know unsung hero of this movie
like because Margot is dazzling
Ryan Gosling is
fantastic but like you need a
human being
in the store I mean Will Ferrell is
fantastic but he's barely playing a
human being he's also something of a
doll himself in the movie like I
feel like Will Ferrell's always like
this might be a bit too much Will
Ferrell
Will Ferrell having a pass key and
hurling it at the gate
for it to open for him to get out of the
building was like one of my favorite
moments of one of my favorite comedic
moments in a movie theater this year
he's trying to get to a turnstile he
need a pass key to get through it he
takes his P he's like so corporate and
so above it all that he does not know
how to get through the turnstile so he
takes his basket and he curls it like
this at the gate it doesn't open he's
like oh
but America Ferrara like
really like I I don't know much like
what was that was she Ugly Betty she was
Ugly Betty yeah
with much that she's been in but
she was phenomenal yeah no she's
really strong because and to your point
she's
she's the human person who gets to
explain to Barbie what the real world
means and what it's like you know and
then to have a daughter who doesn't like
because that's that whole story is the
daughter I like Barbies and she loved
them and but her complicated
relationship with the barber you changed
as she grew up and you know the Barbie
who thinks about death is America
Ferrara that kid was was great too man
like I heard the kid who played her her
daughter a whole thing is
exceptional and
you know a movie like this only comes
along when it happens it instills you
with hope that like oh my God like there
could be more like this I I hadn't even
thought of the Black Panther parallel
but you're absolutely right it's like
holy this is a phenomenon and it's
phenomenon that's serving an audience
that doesn't normally get served but
because of that we all get served like
it's not like oh man I'm left
I'm Moses sitting on the hill outside
the promised land like it raises all
boats yeah
yeah it's a specific story that becomes
Universal because it is specific
and that's the best and imagine imagine
being able to pull off that magic act
once in your life as an artist
let alone to ever do it again I
mean
it's it boy it was a great time
at the movies that reminded me of like
oh yeah like movies can be a lot of
things man just like Barbie can
be a lot of things movies can
also be a lot of things even at
this level you know indie films you
expect like all right they got a soul
and they're not just in it for
the buck this is a movie that by All
Rights
should have and could have just been in
it for the book yeah and somehow
they let it be what it is and because of
that
there's a bunch of kids out there gonna
grow up seeing this movie boys and girls
who are going to be like oh that's what
a movie could be
yeah just one thing that you
know entertains or
passes two hours it can do all that and
make you think and make you feel movies
are very good at making you feel and
most of the time it's artifice
this is a movie literally about a
product predicated in artifice
that somehow makes you feel more
human watching it that's about the best
review I could possibly give that movie
um is all about plastic but it made
me feel like flesh and Bone and soul and
heart
happy I'm happy having seen that movie
so much so that I'm gonna go back again
yeah go for it it's a it's a quicker
watch than Oppenheimer
yeah let's segue over to Oppenheimer man
um I mean listen Oppenheimer you know
the movie you're gonna get to a certain
degree with Oppenheimer it's it's a bit
like like Titanic sooner or later
there's going to be a nice bird
I bet you they're going to grow the bomb
and I bet you it's going to work like
like the story of Jesus
sooner or later there's a third act
where you're like oh Jesus look out
they're coming with a cross yes
um
that's the questionnaires is the thing
and they somehow make a movie and by
they I mean Christopher Nolan makes a
movie that feels like a thriller that
has no thrills because there's no moment
of oh we lost the formula for the
bomb like everything kind of goes the
way it goes you know and yet there's
this pull to it there's this drama to it
there's this inertia to it especially as
you get to the middle of the of the
second act where it's they've built Los
Alamos they've built the town in the
middle of nowhere they've recruited the
scientists that are going to be at the
part of the Manhattan Project and you
know they're building the bomb that it
begins to just feel propulsive in a way
that does not involve car chases or
shootouts or or or suspense as we
conventionally know it but it's all just
people trying their best to do the
impossible thing that nobody's ever done
before
um there is not a bad performance in
this movie like everybody is great
Killian Murphy is phenomenal Florence
Pew remains you know unbeaten at being
Florence Pugh
um you know like okay how's Matt Matt
you know Mass he's he seems to have
settled into this kind of avuncular guy
who gets us gets stuff done for geniuses
like in Ford versus Ferrari he's kind of
playing the same role in that he's got
this race car driver that nobody wants
to trust but he believes in it'll make
you'll move Heaven and Earth it let him
run you know Le man or the Monaco
whatever that is here it's
I've been told you're the best person in
the world who can do this so I'm going
to give you everything you need to do
this tell me when we can test it tell me
when we can set it off but he's great as
you know your Nick Fury of
scientists collecting people to make the
Avengers of setting off bombs if if they
you know when we were kids or in our 20s
they made a movie about the making of
the bomb called fat man and little boy
right who is playing the Paul Newman
part in this movie
um I think it's it's Matt Damon it is
Matt right that's what I got from the
trailer I was like oh I think he's doing
the Paul Newman thing yeah as you
compare the two remotely but they are
about the same subject they're about the
same subject matter
um and so like it's uh it it it plays a
little I'm not gonna say fast at least
with history because there's the history
that's very much committed to and then
there's a history that it's like like
there's this moment where the Matt
Damon's like so where should we build
this fake town that we need to build
where should we test this bomb and
they're in the middle of New Mexico and
and Robin Robin uh JC put up the
spoilers thing man I mean I know it's
tough to spoil a movie that's history
but still we are
I don't want to yell that right and so
we sit in the middle of you know he's
like where should we go until they go
they cut to the middle of New Mexico and
uh and oppenheimer's like there's nobody
around for A Thousand Miles she could
build your city right here we can test
the bomb right over there everything
will be fine
historically was filled with like Native
Americans and Mexican immigrants and
people who had to be displaced in order
to build the city some people who were
not displaced and you know
were were too close to the bomb site and
all got like leukemia in a couple of
years afterwards like the idea that
nobody was there is this like huh
interesting okay sure thing filmmakers
um but
listen it's it's it's I don't know how
they make this movie like I was
literally watching it and I stopped
being able to notice the filmmaking and
just got kind of hypnotized by the story
itself which is exactly what you want as
a filmmaker like stop paying attention
to the artifice stop paying attention to
the the artificiality of narrative in
this way and just get kind of just
invested in it and I was what was the
black and white versus color what was
the
um they do some time hopping you know
it's one of the framing devices is a
sort of inquest hearing that Oppenheimer
is subject to where people come in and
are interviewed and have to tell stories
about this time that we're watching the
prime storyline there's the black and
white stuff which is very much about
Robert Downey Jr as uh he was the head
of the atomic uh advice committee or
something like that that would tell
Truman's government
um what to do and how to deal with what
they had built you know the atom bomb
and then hydrogen bomb and so forth and
so on and so Robert Downey Jr is being
confirmed for a a cabinet post the
Secretary of something or other and so
all the black and white stuff is sort of
that part of the hearing where how that
reflects back on his time with
Oppenheimer in in the post-war era and
then more flashbacks to the building of
the bomb and all it's very it's a little
dunkirky in the way it deals with time
and narrative
um Robert Downey Jr is amazing you know
he's playing he plays um a guy named
Strauss I think who
um
who was a patron of oppenheimer's who
was running University and had
Oppenheimer come in and be the like the
Provost or the dean of atomic whatever
um it's the I'm going to get the Oscar
that I didn't get for chaplain role for
Robert Downey Jr
um I feel like he 100 gets a supporting
actor nomination if not to win somebody
um described the movie I forget who it
was I don't know if it was my friend
John Pearson but they were like it's
Amadeus and yeah Robert Downey Jr is
salieri
there's a bit of that I mean he's not
involved with the building of the bomb
itself he's not part of the Manhattan
Project but it's the jealousy of a guy
who's lived his life close to scientists
but is not a scientist
you know a guy who has been surrounded
by greatness but cannot lay that same
claim you know and and even it's it's
weird because you watch that movie and
you're always a little bit like like the
the Leonardo DiCaprio meme from Once
Upon a Time it's it's that part it's
that part he said the thing when the
first time he says now I am become death
a destroyer of worlds like he said the
thing that we know he says and you see
the various scientists you're like oh
that's Neil's board I remember that name
from somewhere and oh that's that guy
and there's oh that guy that guy's cool
like if you're at all a bit of a science
nerd it becomes like whack-a-mole of
famous science people is that Einstein
over there is that him did his hat just
blow up Albert Einstein isn't it it is
isn't it yeah I know history
but like it's it's a fast three hour sit
um and it's worth it's worth sitting
through because it is it's somewhat
um Majestic filmmaking
um but I can't say I had a better time
than I did at Barbie
um
it sounds like he's got a a future this
this uh young filmmaker Chris Nolan this
Nolan Feller you know I I think he's got
a
he holds promise that's off to that guy
man because I'm telling you like you you
make the movie sound incredibly
compelling and I'm definitely oddly
enough my wife wants to see like
Oppenheimer so hard and I was like
Barbie man Barbie and she's this like
Oppenheimer of the you would imagine it
would be vice versa but I was you know I
was way more interested in seeing Barbie
than I was Oppenheimer um and of course
I was always going to see Oppenheimer
but I think you're cell pushed me over
the edge particularly yourself with
Robert Downey Jr who is like one of my
favorite actors yeah he's great I took
my son to Zion hammer and I was very
surprised when he asked to go
I was like that was the thing about
going to the movies like oh you want to
see Oppenheimer I was like wait you're
19 years old why do you want to see
Oppenheimer
um but he dug it like we left the movie
he's like oh man that was intense that's
his version of that was really good that
was intense it's uh opened huge
like you know considering it's a
three-hour movie about the making of the
nuclear bomb and has no
superheroes in it unless you consider
Oppenheimer like Reed Richards or some
such
um but
like what 87 million or something like
that was their opening yeah I mean they
opened incredibly strong 80 82 million
opening right now worldwide at 419
million dollars that is a those are
comic book movie numbers yeah about
history
um once again you know
you could take
any subject matter
even something as familiar as this
you give it to the right Talent
turns it into something else transcends
the medium not just business-wise
because it's doing killer
business
but like people are dressing up to go
see this movie dressing like
Oppenheimer wearing hats again like in
the 50s or some says a head
Squad yeah man that's that's crazy
um I do look forward to seeing I think
I'm going to see it this weekend
um I always feel like you know
I own a movie theater so I feel
like I'm betraying my movie theater if I
go to other movie theaters but
I'm gonna have to break down and
actually go see it perhaps at a movie
theater out here in Los Angeles did you
see it in 70 my friend Vincent Pereira
who's a big Gearhead when it
comes to movies man
um he went to see it he lives out near
Detroit he went to see it in 70
millimeter and he was like while it
looks beautiful he goes this is a
talking head movie it's like you're not
really gonna miss anything because I was
like should I track down a 70 millimeter
screening which by the way
is difficult
um the 70 millimeter IMAX screenings are
like sold out for weeks in advance still
even now yeah and so they added a 6 a.m
at the Chinese in 70 millimeter
could you imagine I mean waking up at
6am to watch a three-hour movie I've
been making a nuclear bomb
um but uh he he you know he wasn't
dismissive of going live 70 because
he's that guy he loves seven he was like
you should shoot your next movie
he's going it's a talking head movie so
you're not gonna miss anything by not
seeing it in 70 million he's like it's
not like it's a series of sweeping Vista
shots right he's going but inarguably
it's gorgeous and seeing it in
that format is amazing he's going but
considering it's a lot of people talking
you can see it anyway he's like look
just see it that's the point yeah I
didn't see it in 70 because to your
point it was a little difficult too I
want to see it again and I feel like
this second go-around I'll track down
and I'll wait my God gave it a couple of
weeks you know a month and and then I'll
go see it at uh at the Chinese or I
think the uh the City walk out here has
a 7-8 projector that's doing it uh it's
not everywhere but you can find it and
that that gets to be your loophole right
that's how you're not cheating on your
movie theater because you don't have it
in 7D in New Jersey so don't
tell people that we don't have a 70
millimeter theater you're like
let them find out after they bought a
ticket and they're in there and they're
like where's the 70 millimeter like we
ain't got one yeah here's what I want I
want 70 and I don't want Kevin Smith
here
trust me there'd be at least 30 to 40
people who are like oh I ain't paying to
watch it in 70 millimeter with silent
Bill that noise
I mean I got to the point like I've been
invited and this again is the shittiest
first world thing to say and I know but
I've been to enough movie premieres that
I'm now at the point in my life where
I'm like hey you know what uh thank you
for the invite I will pay to go see it
because I get to go in and I'll get out
and there'll be no security I don't have
to check my phone I don't have to deal
with the crowds like I'll go to matinee
of this I'll see it for 15 bucks
and then I'll bounce I love that Chris
Evans is going to be in the house I
don't need him
famous people man they make everything
better don't they
um so two gigantic movies
um uh that we saw one of them we both
saw one of them and then one of us saw
the other
um which we couldn't say enough good
things about like full record
full-throated recommendations for both
it sounds like
absolutely at least for me you got them
um all right so there you go kids
there's your there's your movie reviews
uh tonight I believe the Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles comes out yeah I'm gonna
hopefully see that on Saturday
uh and word has been very positive I
believe they're got a great
rating on Rotten Tomatoes that people
seem to like what's going on there yeah
I mean it looks Seth Rogan joint no
indeed I mean and it looks very much
like oh my God it looks
beautiful it looks like it exists the
way it does because spider-verse exists
the way it does like they it's like they
took the spider-verse Baton and carried
it even further
and it just it looks like art which is
kind of what you want on it but it looks
a little messy which is what you want
out of a movie based on Independent art
and so I'm here for it
um all right I'm looking for power
source for my uh you're winding
down yeah I thought I had a plug here
but then they're just laptop's telling
me this plug ain't doing it I I have a
feeling my computer is gonna sad Max
soon like I know it's it's been it's
shut down twice in the last two days
apropos of nothing and you know I so
much so that I was like boy I better
back up some
but it might be time for a new one man
don't they make this to like
eventually break down on purpose did I
read that someplace yeah yeah you know
it's like they used to make cars that
would last you like 30 years and now you
get five six maybe you know you get
three good years out of a laptop and
then it just starts to get funky
like a battery power in phones are kind
of designed to begin to lose their
charge after years
allegedly do not come and sue me Apple
um I better stop trying to plug it in
unless it sad Mac while I'm in
the middle of the show
you know that's all right we got a half
an hour left anyway yeah that's true we
got to do kids all right let's talk
about uh the other let's talk about some
news let's hit some news real quick
um apparently allegedly according to an
interview with comicbook.com
Gal Gadot might be back for Wonder Woman
three after all
um in promoting her movie uh Heart of
Stone which may or may not be coming out
on a platform that may or may not be a
streamer
um she alluded to hearing from the new
DC bosses James Gunn Peter saffron about
developing a third Wonder Woman movie
together
I love portraying Wonder Woman get it
out said about the third movie it's so
close to and dear to my heart from what
I've heard from James and from Peter is
that we're going to develop a Wonder
Woman 3 together
which is somewhat reversing of course
from kind of everything we'd heard
before the Patty Jenkins of it all that
she she sort of left the movie after you
know I guess pitching it to to James and
to Peter who maybe didn't got into it
too much
um
and we don't know if she has anything to
do with Superman Legacy
which will be you know kickoff in 2025
we know that there's a new Superman we
know that there's going to be a new
Batman at some point and so is it
possible that she's the only real
holdover from the previous version of
the DC
extended universe
who knows
so I'll still wet clay but
I mean it looks it looks like it
releases conversations so good for all
parties concerned
I loved Wonder Woman that was a
wonderful flick
um we got to see her a little bit in
Flash but a lot of people were like ew
what a flash
um let's talk about Lando
Lando yeah Lando's a quicker talk than
Aquaman 2 because we have a lot to talk
about recommend too but um but about a
week ago or so Justin Simeon the
director writer director of The Haunted
Mansion was on the the red carpets
um the only member of the the creative
team that could be because according to
his contract with the Director's Guild
he still had to promote the movie that
he made even though he was on strike as
a writer
um but he talked about he was asked
about the Lando show and he was like as
far as I know it's still happening I
think so but I haven't heard in a while
and then this week we heard what is
happening with the Lando show which is
Donald Glover and his brother Stephen
Glover have signed on to write
lucasfilm's Lando series for Disney Plus
um apparently the deal was made prior to
the writer strike uh so it was not an
act of negotiations and I guess just now
came out
it's hard to to really understand why
now was the time they decided to release
this information other than people were
talking about Lando I guess
um but you know Donald Glover has always
um and by always I mean for the last
couple of years talked very warmly about
playing Lando and said I would love to
play land of again it's a fun time being
him it just has to be the right way to
do it Tom is precious the past couple of
years this pandemic really had
people experience time people realize
their time is valuable uh it just has to
be the right thing and I think it could
be Lando was definitely something I'd
like to hang out with it was a quote
from GQ back in April so if you love
Donald Glover if you loved Atlanta and
if you love his version of Lando it
seems like you're going to get a
completely uncut Donald Glover Lando
show
I'm here for it I thought he did a great
job in Solo man
yeah I mean I haven't I haven't
re-watched Solo in a long time like I
just remember not loving it in the
theater
um and I have never Revisited it but I
remember he was certainly not the part
of the problem no I remember he was he
was having a blast and then which is
kind of exactly what you want from from
The Young Lando just be kind of having
it
people seem to love Atlanta so you know
it's not like he's very talented so yeah
control the material for heaven's sakes
absolutely knows what he's doing
um Aquaman 2 uh and the kingdom of
reshoots
uh according to this uh this Hollywood
Reporter article
um they've now gone through three rounds
of reshoots for the James Juan movie uh
the sequel to the 2018 film that made uh
1.148 billion dollars the highest
grossing DC movie of all time was I was
I was gonna say like this is a movie
that made a billion dollars yes in a
billion dollars so naturally it behooved
them they're like let's do it again
let's do it again it's been troubled to
say the least it sounds like to say the
least
um the third round of reshoots is is an
almost an unprecedented number even for
movie this scale
um it was supposed to come out
um in December of 2022 it's now
potentially coming out December 20th of
23 depending on if this is a thing that
gets moved because of the active strike
or not
um it's endured three regimes at Warner
Brothers
um Toby emmerich and Walter Hamada were
one regime and then when the Warner
Brothers Discovery merger happened Mike
Deluca and Pamela Abdi who were the new
Warner Brothers film bosses who came
involved
um they've had at least two rounds of
reshoots between summer of 2022 and
beginning of 2023 and had a bunch of
uninspiring test screenings
um then Deluca and Abdi got involved
um but that even led to another round of
reshoots because their editorial
versions specifically Pamela Abdi got
involved in her version was testing
lower than previous versions it's
and then they got arrested with the
Batman of it all like Walter Hamada had
wanted Michael Keaton's version of the
character to be like Nick Fury in the
Marvel movies and Elder Statesman who
can pop in he was supposed to be in
Batgirl clearly The Flash also the lost
kingdom but then when Batgirl went away
and the release date shifted they
decided that like not let's not promise
a version of Batman that people are not
going to see going forward so Ben
Affleck did a round of reshoots and then
that's a version of Batman we may not
ever see again so then they decided to
pull Batman out almost entirely I think
um and then more test screenings where
this February but by now James Gunn gets
involved and Peter Safran and now so gun
is weighed in on the most recent cut
approved another five-day version of
reshoots like this is just the movie
that keeps on getting made over and over
and over again
it started at a 205 million dollar
budget which during the pandemic is when
it the first round of the initial
production was and that becomes an
expensive proposition and now
all of these reshoots are just adding to
that tally
I you know it sounds like a mess
uh it's hard to tell
JC is the host now
um I don't even know if we're online he
said it's coming back
okay yeah my internet just went nuts uh
hold on I'm gonna put the screen up and
mute us for a second and then we'll be
right back
uh hold on I think it's Valley heat or
something uh we'll be right back I'm
gonna get everything back online
okay we're back
we're good everything's fixed
hey kids sorry about that uh we're two
of us I think all three I see two of me
is Mark
yeah there we go hello
um all three of us are now in the valley
well now it's me again
is this something I should worry about
JC
okay I gotta fixed
um all three of us are in the valley and
Valley heat may be killing
killing us somehow yeah rolling Brown
ads internet's gonna internet uh so
let's let's
uh make sure that we get to everything
before we lose power
Aquaman sounds like it's doing great
barreling steam Wentworth to December
20th release
so there they haven't announced they
haven't announced the movie yet but I
think that Warner Brothers is is maybe
buried by by Barbie maybe trying to hold
the course and keep their false slate
the way they they designed it but I
think much will much will tell in the
next couple of weeks depending on strike
business they could charge me fifty
dollars a ticket just to see the cut
Michael Keaton Ben Affleck Batman stuff
just make it Aquaman 2 the Lost Batman
scene
I don't care how long it is I'll overpay
to see that
how the does something that like I
mean I don't know I've never worked at
that level but like
the first one was a runaway hit
all you gotta do is more of the same and
for some reason boy they hit
wall after wall after wall water wall
with this yeah man I don't know
Aquaman 2 Titanic
hitting the iceberg
um Jason Momoa always seems like such a
nice guy it's a shame but he was out
there depressed going like look I gave
him ideas and they didn't want to hear
my so even he was kind of backing
off of the movie
uh
all right all right let's
let's hit the sadness
I I have one more I have one quick weird
piece of news which is uh Magic the
Gathering which is like the grandfather
of all uh
playing card games right uh released a
Lord of the Rings set of cards and there
was a single one ring card that they
only made one of like sauron's one ring
one out of all the cards they printed
and post Malone just bought that card
from the Canadian guy who got it in a
pack for 2.6 million dollars
I've never wanted to be a Canadian guy
more in my life
one of the most expensive trading cards
ever sold
um it's uh
that's nuts
to post Malone
to post Malone the rock star guy with
tattoos everywhere uh apparently is a
giant nerd
with enough money to buy a 2.6 million
dollar trading card that's my favorite
part of the story is like stars they're
just like us
except I would never pay two points I
don't give a if they were like
we'll give you all the Batman footage
cut out of Batgirl out of uh
Aquaman whatever the Michael Keaton
only
I don't know that I'd cough up 2.6
million dollars for anything shy of
something one could live in
sadness
um Paul Rubens
who disappeared behind the Thai great
suit and a bright red bow tie to
creating Stars the awkward man shot PB
Herman
uh has passed away at 70 years old
um on the statement that that was
released on Monday when he passed on his
official Facebook page I said last night
we said farewell to Paul Rubin the
iconic American actor comedian writer
and producer whose beloved character PB
Herman delighted generations of
children's and adults with his
positivity Whimsy and belief in the
importance of kindness Paul bravely and
privately fought cancer for years with
his trademark tenacity and wit A Gifted
and prolific Talent he will forever live
in the comedy Pantheon and in our hearts
as a treasured friend and a man of
remarkable character and generosity of
spirit
he uh I put up a tweet about this the
other day because uh discussing films
where I read it said Paul Rubens wrote a
message before he passed away last night
and this is the message Paul had written
um
please accept my apology
for not going public with what I've been
facing the last six years I have always
felt a huge amount of love and respect
from my friends fans fans and supporters
I have loved you all so much and enjoyed
making art for you
it's beautiful man like this is
a man who was dying I tweeted
that like I know me like if I was going
through a thing if I had a
hangnail you wouldn't not hear about it
you would I wouldn't be I wouldn't be me
if I wasn't online telling you
every single detail
about the pain and the agony and trying
to claim as much attention and
relevancy as I could from my
disease this guy told nobody
yeah kept it quiet fought his fight by
himself and then apologized
before he died for not sharing that kind
of information
this is the tweet that I put up with it
just because I don't think I'll be able
to sell it say it quite as eloquently
I said I know me I'd be posting about my
struggles on The Daily milking it until
my last breath desperate for attention
and relevancy but not Paul Reubens if
I'm not at least trying to be a person
this classy and considerate in life then
maybe it's time I start thanks Peewee I
mean for the gift of comedy and laughs
and love that this dude gave us for
decades I I taped the Pee Wee Herman
show off HBO on a betamax tape
when I was a pre when I was in before my
20s when I was a teenager before
they even made peewee's big adventure
when Phil Hartman was zombie the genie
Mecca luckaha Mecca honey chani ho
this guy's been doing it for
decades this guy was in The Blues
Brothers
been around for a long time and
PeeWee of course like his best known
creation and and
giving joy and love and laughter
and like that quote destroyed me
when I read that thank you let's let's
read that again man that's the last
words
of one of the greatest artists of the
20th century
please accept my apology for not going
public with what I've been facing the
last six years I have always felt a huge
amount of love and respect from my
friends fans and supporters I have loved
you all so much and enjoyed making art
for you
that was an artist
and went out like an artist just happy
that he got to make some art for us
he made me laugh
he made me think
he made me feel things made me happy to
be alive he gave me currency at one
point when I was a kid and taped that
show off of HBO I passed it around to
friends and who made made me
look good people were like how'd you
find this I'm like well it was on HBO
I didn't exactly discover people
but um we lost somebody great man 70
years old far too young
yeah remember him and Mystery Men as
well
that's right spleen
I mean how he's in a bunch of he's in a
couple of Cheech and Chong movies that's
how far he goes back you're right saw a
trailer recently
for uh nice streams and he was in the
trailer I think
um but you know I'm a Loner
Dottie a rebel come on
yeah yeah I mean it's he was he he was
not a perfect person I don't think
anybody is and he had his he had his
affordables and his weaknesses and his
you know dalliances with the law but all
of which he owned up to all of which he
you know served whatever Penance he
needed to serve for
um but just seems to very much love
being Pee-wee Herman and would be PeeWee
Herman until the end and just love
performing and loved to your point
making people laugh
you know taking all that inspiration
from like howdy Duty and Captain
Kangaroo and Rocky and Bullwinkle and
channeling it into this character
reinvented the Groundlings in the late
70s and tries to get on SNL with it and
they don't buy that they decided they
don't want PB Herman on SNL
um
and then took it to previous pb's
Playhouse and like yeah freaking
Lawrence Fishburne is in pb's Playhouse
you know like ASAP Murchison is who
through these Playhouse philomar friend
of the show is on pb's Playhouse I mean
it was this amazing I think they won 22
Emmys for that
and that was the that was the show that
he did for CBS
Pee-wee's Playhouse the thing that I
taped off HBO was just a version of his
live show that he did on stage for years
uh the Pee-wee Herman show
um that was before the movie before the
Emmys on the on the CBS kids
Morning Show
it's it sucks that anybody has to die
but like when people who brought
so much to happiness to the world
um go it's particular blow and those
final words man
that's
any any will always be a nerd for lots
of reasons but hey man he was penguin's
dad
in Batman Returns right man he
threw penguin out tossed him into the
sewer in a wordless performance
what was that movie The Johnny Depp
movie about blow oh yeah
like this is a guy who could do a bunch
of different things man but like
thank God he had the presence of mind to
be like I'm gonna put on this suit and
little this little bow tie and
pretend to be a kid we got so
much out of that change the culture man
change the culture
put a dent in the universe
Jeff's kiss B we Herman Jeff's kiss Paul
Rubens The Man Behind Pee Wee Herman
it's a shame
we all gotta go but like some
cats you hope can hold on forever and
stuff
yeah reminds me a little bit of Chadwick
Boseman who had been suffering from
cancer for a long time working through
it you know that he while making you
know Civil War while making Infinity War
like he was sick
but you know kept on strapping
on the armor and going to work
we only get a short time kids that's it
doesn't matter who you are
you know death even for Kings it comes
even for Peewee it came
so make sure you do some stuff in this
life
good stuff positive stuff
as Mark said on last episode when we
were at San Diego Comic Con be good
and being good means like doing
good for people the Paul Reubens did a
lot of good for people probably made the
difference between life and death for
some people look I know if the
I've made every once in a while
people are like your saved my life
and that's my that means that
PeeWee Herman saved a lot of
lives he brightened up their
dark days and kept people hanging on
that's what art does man
it's a beacon of light in the dark
so true
um yeah
it's a bummer yeah I'm a bummer
just
we're on a journey kids and we only got
Journey only goes in One Direction sadly
but man we were lucky to have had him at
all
never mind lamenting the fact
that he's not here anymore let's
celebrate the fact he did it at all
brightened up the world
for the time that he was here shine
while you're here my friends
for the darkness claims us all as Mark
said earlier in the show
winter is coming
copyright trademark Mark Bernardin it's
mine nobody else's
five percent so my is about to die
so we should probably wrap this up we're
gonna wrap it up no q a this day no q a
this day so much news so much catching
up but next time there'll be a q a
um and I'm I imagine the next time maybe
in New Jersey unless we stream a show
prior to that I'm sure we'll we'll
figure it out of that kids do you have a
good time I know I did
you got to thank JC Banff man himself
for getting this to you and
saved us when fell apart
does that mean there's two YouTube files
on online no it didn't disconnect long
enough to
to cut it and start a new one so we got
lucky
well done heroic effort my friends uh
there ain't no show without the guy
who's over there over there God I could
never do this down there
here's the story
Mark Bernardin uh there's your fat man
beyond for this week kids go out and see
Barbie go out and see Oppenheimer go
watch peewee's big adventure or some
Pee-wee's Playhouse in memory of Paul
Rubens indeed for Aquaman though
looks bleak
the fact that we're gonna get a Lando
series uh
and perhaps Wonder Woman's not gone
after all indeed out there there's also
a Comic-Con Cruise coming apparently did
you see that news I did I did man
they're doing a cruise for Comic Con I
think we talked about it at Hollywood
Babylon at Comic-Con this year uh
Comic-Con is doing an official cruise
but you know what so are we hell yeah
want to come on cruise to skew and hang
out with me and Mark and
and Jason Muse and Ralph Garman
and Jeff Anderson Brian o'holler Trevor
Fuhrman a bunch of people from my movies
and stuff go to Jay and Silent Bob
cruisesque.com and join up we're at 75
sold this thing don't happen until
February so you and 3 000 other
fans of the nonsense I do at sea
what could go wrong yes
to become like Lord of the flies
could become like Gilligan's Island with
3 000 of us and think about coconut
radios we'll be able to build
um thank you as always for paying
attention to us even for this brief
window of time kids
uh that's your fat man beyond for this
week for fat man beyond
I'm uh Kevin Smith and I'm Mark Bernard
tune in next time same fat Time same fat
channels podcast.com or youtube.com
Kevin Smith Jeff's kiss
be good
[Music]
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old off Kevin
Smith
[Music]